we are about to see vice president mike
pence get the coronavirus vaccine
in a public demonstration of support
we're going out to washington where the
vice president is getting the shot
along with his wife karen pence and u.s
surgeon general
dr jerome adams the white house arranged
this public vaccination as a way to
reassure people who are skeptical about
getting
the vaccine themselves let's listen in
over here
all right
all righty
awesome
that's great great job great job
so before you guys leave today you'll be
getting a shot record proving that you
receive the vaccine from us today
and this vaccine is a two dose series so
that means you'll need to come back in
21 days for the second one
again with any vaccine you could have a
pretty sore arm at the injection site
maybe some redness but if anything else
happens make sure to contact a medical
provider or go see medical care okay
great thank you thank you
well good morning and thank you all for
being here i want to thank my wonderful
wife our second lady karen pence
the surgeon general and dr tony fauci
and
members of the white house coronavirus
task force who are joining us
here today i especially want to thank
the fine medical team
at walter reed hospital that
administered our vaccine today
i didn't feel a thing well done
and we appreciate your service to the
country you know as the christmas
holiday approaches this is always a
season of hope
we gather here today at the end of a
historic week
to affirm to the american people that
hope is on the way
and karen and i were more than happy to
step forward
before this week was out to take this
safe
and effective coronavirus vaccine that
we have secured and produced
for the american people it's a truly
inspiring day
as the people of this country witnessed
this uh this past week under operation
warp speed
the first coronavirus vaccine is
literally being administered
in states across the country to millions
of americans
and make no mistake about it it's a
medical miracle
the average vaccine i'm told by our
experts usually takes between 8
and 12 years to develop and then
manufacture and distribute
but we're on track here in the united
states to administer
millions of doses to the american people
in less than one year it is a miracle
indeed
and i also believe that history will
record that this week
was the beginning of the end of the
coronavirus pandemic
but with cases rising across the country
with hospitalizations rising across the
country
vice president mike pence after taking
the corona by the pfizer coronavirus
vaccine he said he didn't feel a thing
we heard joan
joined by ben tracy at the white house
ben good morning
a very public display here by the vice
president the big signs behind him say
safe and effective
trying to rally the country to get this
vaccine going
yeah exactly anthony this is not just a
photo op this really is a concerted
effort by the white house to try to
instill
confidence in this vaccine because they
know there is this significant
anti-vaxxer movement in this country in
that some of those people are supporters
of the trump administration so they're
trying to give this message that the
vaccine
is safe and effective they want people
to take this vaccine when it is their
turn to do so
and the reason for that is that we need
about 70 percent of people in this
country to be vaccinated
either by getting the shot or by already
having coronavirus
to reach what they call herd immunity so
we can get back to some semblance of
normal life
so that is the message from the white
house this morning after a lot of mixed
messages from this administration
about coronavirus over the last the last
year and even from the vice president
himself keep in mind just about six
months ago
he wrote an op-ed saying there's no
second wave of coronavirus and we've
seen in recent days
him hosting a holiday party with people
with no masks on
so this is an effort at least today to
say do as we do and
uh do as we say well ben the the signage
as anthony pointed out behind the vice
president there says stay
safe and effective and the science
supports that so the follow-up question
has to be when might we see
the president himself take this vaccine
particularly because
a lot of people believe what he has to
say and he has flirted with anti-vax
positions in the past so it could be
very important to see him come forward
and take this on camera
yeah and we've been asking the white
house about that all week and they've
really dodged the question the president
himself tweeted out saying that he looks
forward to taking the vaccine at the
appropriate time but he's not currently
scheduled to do so
of course he is the president of the
united states so anytime he wants to get
the vaccine now
he could actually get the vaccine the
white house also is saying that keep in
mind the president did have coronavirus
that he was given one of those antibody
treatments so they
say that he is protected but to your
point it would be a good message for the
country a good message for a lot of the
president's supporters
if they saw him doing this as well yeah
would be hugely symbolic ben thank you
very much